that is the death toll in Italy has
risen by 919 and now stands at nine
thousand one hundred thirty four we can
now speak to Sally Lockwood who is in
Rome and Sally another big rise in
Italian numbers yes mark I can't quite
believe we're seeing these numbers 919
people have lost their lives in the last
24 hours in Italy that is by far the
biggest loss of life in a 24-hour period
not just in Italy but globally if I'm
not mistaken the biggest loss of life in
a single day in Italy so far before this
figure was 765 I'll need to check that
to be sure but it was around that so 919
is a huge leap and to think that it was
just the 21st of February exactly five
weeks ago today that Italy lost its
first citizen to covet 19 and the number
now stands at nine thousand one hundred
and thirty-four lives lost in just five
weeks
it's impossible to imagine what that
feels like for the people working on the
front line of doctors and nurses we know
now that 14% of the positive cases are
frontline health care workers and of
course the number of cases in Italy has
risen as well today significantly to
86,000 498 up from 80 in eighty thousand
five hundred around that point yesterday
that's eclipsed
China's number of reported figures which
was around 81 thousand we did expect
that to exceed China's figures today but
I don't think anyone expected
the death toll to be quite that size
mark 919 lives lost in a 24-hour period
Italy's biggest loss of life so far and
I can also tell you that in Lombardi
today mark 541 people are said to have
lost their lives in the last 24 hours
bringing the number of lives lost just
in the Lombardy region alone to 5400 and
to a very very sharp rise compared to
yesterday and if I'm not mistaken the
second-highest loss of life in Lombardi
in a single day so far so
very disappointing news for Italy today
mark as they are well into their third
week in lockdown with no end date in
sight yeah thanks very much indeed Sally
and that is an increase in 24 hours of
919 in Italy bigger than the total
number of deaths here in the UK